>> Well, yeah, of course.
You know, I think the question is a given
that India is going to be a
superpower.
Why it is a given is because it has a fundamental,
some fundamentals of
the particular establishment.
The political system, the democracy, the ability
for people to
innovate, grow, prosper.
And they are such an empowered to be entrepreneurial
and create their
own value and contribution to the economy.
The question is when?
And what can we do to really make it was fast
as possible, and to have
systems and processes in place for it to be
more inclusive sooner
rather than much later.
I think that would be the key thing we all
should work towards in India
and in formulating policies.
And the government should be working on empowerment,
to have more
contributions from not just some sections
of the society, towards that
role of India of becoming a superpower, but
more importantly for
everybody to take part in that process as
soon as possible.
Thanks.